hi this is John Delaney and my good
friend Rachel Cruz and we are crazy
during Corona and I want to talk about
something that his the the folks had
reaching out to me across the country
have been asking about and it has
actually been driving me bananas it is
the what overwhelming amount of
information nonsense
news everywhere all the all the places
it's constant it's constant it's insane
and I might not be a great expert to
talk okay so tell me about it all the
information what's it doing to your head
and your soul
those are two separate entities okay
I like to look at the numbers so I
always go to like the daily like count
of like what's happening like okay it
sounds terrible but it's true of like
how many cases are there how many people
have like you know we're covered from
how you've passed away from it like I
just like I become a numbers like junkie
because when I hear on the news like
so-and-so City it's by 22 percent I'm
like what does it mean 20 percent of
water for people I have to do my own
right so that's I mean I think I do my
own research because I'd like you watch
different things and they're giving you
like why is that half of the information
why is it not having no idea on I don't
know I don't know and it could just be
me overthinking it but I like to go to
like just the numbers so that's but then
I watch the news every day and then I
watch the nightly news too which is just
it's just I don't know why and it's the
same stories
students saying like if you watch the
same network so I'm like what am i doing
i I'm an information overload so you
need to help me actually probably just
is what's been so weird about my world I
haven't watched the news like in 8 or 9
years right I have a Salaria story about
hanging out one evening at a restaurant
in Airport with senator Ted Cruz we're
just hanging out had no idea who he was
serious until somebody came up I mean
we're just laughing being dads
prymaat raising kids so I'm so
disconnected from politics I'm so
disconnected and stay out why because
you don't cuz care it's just nothing you
don't care you just I care but it
occurred to me gosh maybe eight or nine
years ago that the the chief objective
of
especially news companies was my
attention not to give me information
that was useful in my day yeah and so
the players like I've met reporters I've
met cameramen I've got I've got news
people in my family they're incredible
people they are doing a public service
but it's this idea globally that their
job is to get me to focus and not to
give me correct info and so that may
make the graphs a little bit more dark
red or the alarms a little bit more
right yeah yes for sure for sure I knew
by myself I could handle any more like I
just had to check out and so I developed
this is a Dicky to go a couple of folks
I trusted about health stuff and a
couple of folks I trusted about economic
stuff and then more importantly I
developed excited some friends who were
bankers or some friends who worked over
in this area the site and I would ask
them hey let me know what's going on but
when this came online
it struck close to home because it was
unique because it they weaponized people
people are the problem right our
neighbor or so true right exactly and so
but my kid could go play and come back
and it could be carrying this thing is
it totally yes myself
more drawn to more info and in a way
that I haven't been in a while and I'll
tell you what man two days three days in
I'm just right scroll through right yes
and tell I had to just put the brakes on
it yeah had to put the brakes on and I
got a deal with everyone in my life
getting their information do you have
people turning this into an information
competition oh yeah and I'm probably
part of it no no I think that's that's
wrong
I'm telling you this is like my weakness
and I need to I really do need to put a
boundary up personally because and you
know that's probably better than I even
do but I'm like the information you take
in like it's in there
right like what you consume whether it's
social media entertainment news like
what it fill in the blank it goes in
your mind so I'm like what am i put I'm
white that's genius
oh it doesn't come out it just stays in
there stays in there it becomes a part
unless you're around me too much and I
tell you about all my coronavirus that's
a 900 that way but really the only okay
so I do need to like I
there were moments for sure throughout
this whole thing where I'm like oh I
can't watch I don't want to do today
like I haven't done it literally every
single day but it's been enough where
I'm like I need to pull back probably
just for like my own sanity you know the
information is coming from anywhere
right right right totally time cuz you
can go like weird conspiracy route was
we were all in here we want here better
like even if I go to the CDC gov which
is like true facts right you know much
but the government I don't like dude I'm
saying you can go down this rabbit hole
it's like never ending right that's
records I think mine's a control thing
but if like if I have the knowledge or
something I can control it and am i
weird unhealthy way I can manipulate it
to make me feel okay you don't say
absolutely I'm too Pollyanna sometimes
and I think I can like look at things or
- personal and I'm like okay but see
it's not that like I just I can like
shift the reality to what I need to be
okay okay so you just said something
important and I want everyone to hear
this it's important for us to realize
that we often go after information that
confirms what we already believe or that
we desperately want to be true yes does
that make sense yes this confirmation
bias idea right confirmation bias and so
there's a couple of dangerous things
here like when this first started I
remember we were all in New York
together I was laughing about it I had a
couple of buddies who were local doctors
back in Texas and we were cracking up
about it which wasn't that big of a deal
totally totally but those the people I
was surrounding myself with right and I
remember being in New York and we're
walking downtown Manhattan and I
remember this thought like what if we're
wrong right there's a bunch of people
not outside and they're closing down
Broadway and this and that
yes all the week we're literally the
date the two are there they're gonna
yeah and so it's super important to
remember to either a go outside your
comfort zone find out what other people
are saying yes yes or turn off right so
what is your recommendation for folks as
we are just getting this onslaught of
information how do we take care of
ourselves
yeah I mean I would say I know for me
I'm like I just need if you need a
little bit of the information right and
you're like hey I can handle it I'm
doing it in a somewhat healthy
processing way just like have boundaries
around this so like okay I'm gonna watch
20 minutes of this news thing right here
and I would be done like dude I'm saying
like
put boundaries and limits to it because
it can be unless it can I mean it's just
it's constant right now so you have to
have some kind of boundary in your life
when it comes to it so what I'm trying
to do I'm not sticking to it perfectly
but I'm trying to do is I can check in
the morning I can check in the afternoon
yeah and that's it yeah yeah and
especially not at nighttime because then
I end up it's 11:45 a.m. 3:00 p.m.
whatever time at nighttime yeah I've got
a bit like at 8:30 so 11:45 basically
the next day and so but yeah you end up
yeah all the sudden for sure for sure my
tin hat is tall and airy and so a couple
of takeaways number one remember the
information you were drawn to is
probably something you already believe
or that you want desperately to be true
so if you're gonna be searching
information find the multiple sources go
to the CDC website go to the John
Hopkins website and the second thing is
is set boundaries and stick to them the
best you possibly can getting it feels
like this thing is changing every day
and it's really not right it's really
not and then this is a third thing that
I think is important most of us are not
epidemiologists most of us are not like
virus experts most of us are not macro
micro economists yeah so everything that
we're saying we're making it up or just
regurgitating with somebody who we want
so badly to be right to say yes right
yes why is that important for this one
reason let's just be compassionate
moving forward let's just be kind is
gonna be so tempting to say I told you
so or we overreacted or you didn't react
enough or thank God we did all this
social distancing gonna close everything
down for 30 days but let's just stop
just done let's be kind and gracious to
one another this is John Delaney a good
for Rachael Cruz protect your hearts and
your heads from all this information
coming from everywhere and take care of
your loved ones see you soon